if I'm laying down with a man butt naked  and his condom is on and I say you know  what no I don't want to do this I  changed my mind  okay that means no right that means if  you see a basketball player and he's  known as a basketball player when you  see him you'll be like yo let's go play  ball just like it's the energy that's  being sent out there that creates that  type of response  it doesn't matter how far I take it or  what I have won  now I say I wouldn't if I were to wear a  short skirt or a tank top and I'm at the  club and I'm having fun with my friends  and I feel sexy  I'm not DTF I'm not I don't know even  looking at you I don't even want to have  sex with you I might I didn't come here  to have sex I'm not asking for nothing  okay okay